et avec nous pour en parler ce soir jean
philippe dugoin mère udi de même si
bonsoir jean philippe dugoin vous êtes
également vice-président de la région
ile-de-france à vos côtés pour en
débattre aurélien lecoq porte parole de
la france insoumise bonsoir à tous les
deux merci d'être avec nous pour revenir
tout d'abord sur ces mises en examen à
la majorité embarrassé a notamment par
la mise en examen de l'ancien ministre
de la santé je vous propose d'écouter le
commentaire de ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'était ce matin chez nos
confrères de lci
moi ce qui m'inquiète ce n'est pas la
judiciarisation de la politique mais la
judiciarisation de la démocratie une
ligne rouge a été franchie
jean philippe dugoin clément on a vu pas
mal d'embarras avec cette mise en main
en examen d'agnès musan vous quelle est
votre position sur ce sujet
non je comprends que le gouvernement
serait en effet cette situation née à
huit mois d'une présidentielle et on
voit qu'il ya potentiellement un fils
une pelote qui peut être tiré exploiter
politiquement au delà de ça il ya deux
sujets qui se posent là dessus la
première c'est la responsabilité
collective administrative d'une
structure qu'il s'agit de l'état d'une
collectivité locale d'un hôpital très
bien ce qu'il faut logique
d'indemnisation de recherche de
responsabilités et puis la deuxième
chose ce qui se produit ici et qui pour
le coup m'interpelle beaucoup plus c'est
la responsabilité personnelle du
ministre
intuiti personae sur des choix
politiques n'étant pas des choix
délictuelle n'étant pas le fait de
loutres passer une réglementation de ne
pas respecter une réglementation est
donc alors même qu'une crise est en
cours il n'est pas terminée on est
aujourd'hui quasiment seul pays à
rentrer sur ce type d'action galles
italie mais il ya le prix dans le monde
qui le fou ce qui a été montré lé
témoignage vous avez enregistré et
bouleversant mais des témoignages si
l'on peut retrouver dans énormément pays
parce que je train sur ce type d'action
le fait de rentrer sur une mise en cause
d'une responsabilité pénale d'un élu
mais on exactement la même chose sur un
air avec un arbre qui va tomber avec ses
histoires du panier de basket qui tombe
et qui blesse quelqu'un sait qu'après
une décision politique un jean philippe
dugoin clémente aussi on peut toujours
retrouver une décision politique parce
qu'on va vous dire que ça ne va pas été
entretenues que j'ai eu un défaut de
surveillance il un défaut d'entretien ce
qui se pose là c'est la généralisation
de ce qu'on appelait le syndrome furiani
à une époque qui risque et qui peut
c'était d'ailleurs décrit par le
secrétaire général du conseil
constitutionnel tout simplement aboutir
à une cessation de l'action politique
quand un élu va avoir pour principal
souci dans une prise de décision de
chercher à se couvrir de chercher à
limiter une responsabilité politique
ultérieur je suis pas convaincu que
l'action politique la démocratie fait un
nom par aurélia lecoq vous partager
cette opinion
c'est pas moi de juger si la mise en
examen est légitime ou pas si la cour de
justice de la république a décidé qu'il
devait y avoir une mise en examen et ce
n'est pas un jugement et qui aura
jugement derrière on verra s'il
considère que ce que craignaient du sein
est responsable et coupable et
juridiquement de quelque chose mais
c'est pas à moi d'en juger après on
parle de la question de la
responsabilité pénale des hommes et des
femmes politiques qui ont été en
fonction quoi ça vous met effectivement
dans notre dans notre pays c'est comme
ça personne n'est au dessus des lois et
en l'occurrence la non-assistance à
personne en danger est effectivement un
délit et tout le monde peut en être
responsable c'est effectivement le cas
de ceux qui nous gouvernent des membres
du gouvernement
le cas effectivement d'élus locaux mais
souvent vous aimez faire des parallèles
avec la vie réelle les entreprises les
petits commerçants mais c'est le cas de
tout le monde tout citoyen français est
pénalement responsable
de ses actes alors dans le cas d'espèce
sous ce n'est pas la politique qui doit
être jugée si à un moment on considère
que agnès buzyn avait des éléments
qu'elle était en capacité d'estimer un
danger et qu à l'arc et qu'elle n'a pas
réagi pour des raisons diverses et
variées par exemple parce que ça coûtait
trop cher ou une autre raison si c'est
le cas alors oui c'est quoi et oui c'est
normal qu'il puisse y avoir un jugement
mais si ce n'est pas le cas alors elle
ne sera pas elle ne sera pas rendu
coupable mais si la justice décide de se
saisir de la faire il faut que ça puisse
aller que ça puisse aller aujourd'hui 41
ans après ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
n'est pas à nier ce besoin d'être le
fusible du gouvernement et de la débâcle
du gouvernement sur la gestion de la
crise qu vide il faut aussi que chacun
assume ses responsabilités y compris le
président de la république et que lui il
assume ses responsabilités de manière
politique en arrêtant de prendre
l'ensemble des décisions sous le couvert
du secret défense et puis qu'ils se
rendent par exemple devant le parlement
pour pouvoir rendre compte de décisions
qu'il prend jean-philippe pas du moins
clément justement
notre ami parler de deux fusibles sur la
même ligne d'ailleurs que bruno le maire
bernard henri lévy lui dénoncé un climat
de populisme général est ce que
justement pour reprendre ses termes
est-ce que agnès buzyn est un fusible un
bouc-émissaire nous sommes dans une
inclinaison de populisme pénal il faut
entre guillemets pardonnez moi
l'expression se payer des politiques
et j'en sais rien risquer ce qui était
assez qu'elle diffuse un ministre d'un
gouvernement qui comprend un ministre et
le premier ministre qui est nommé par le
président de la république dans une
concentration des pouvoirs et un
exercice d'iter concentration du pouvoir
qu'on a jamais connu depuis la création
de la vème république et pourtant
pouvoir ultracentralisée
bon et évidemment si agnès buzyn
elise en cause ou attaquer l'une manière
ou d'une autre on peut imaginer que ça
commence à tirer une pelote de laine ce
qui est extrêmement gênant pour ce
gouvernement met véritablement pour moi
la question font là dessus c'est
quasiment un débat philosophique je
lisais
l'autre intervenant sait s'il est une
irrégularité quelque chose qui a été
cachée très bien si ça n'est pas le cas
qu'on est sur le choix d'une action une
appréciation politique dans quelle
mesure s au juge de se substituer à
l'électeur pour aller à postériori juge
est de savoir si les décisions qui ont
été prises ont été bonnes ou mauvaises
et le glissement on peut un crapaud qui
peut être risqué c'est celui-là a
posteriori quelle est la responsabilité
individuelle de quelqu'un qui aura pris
des prises de position pour tel ou tel
type de soins pour tel ou tel type
d'action fort tel ou tel type de
protocole dans des établissements
publics c'est ça qui peut se poser
derrière et au fond le risque c'est quoi
c'est que vous ayez à des ministres qui
le jour où il se retrouve nommé en poste
à une fonction fois dans une logique de
lanaken la couverture systématique en
disant chacun de leur acte politique
pourra donner est mieux à une mise en
cause juridique et pénales c'est ça qui
est dangereux dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur l'europe pour le reste
effectivement des jugements qu'ils
soient
je comprends bien je comprends bien ce
que vous dites mais vous le dites vous
même si on arrive à démontrer le fait
qu'il ya une mise en danger et
consciente de la vie d'autrui parce
qu'il y avait des informations connues
qui n'ont pas été utilisés correctement
vous trouvez que c'est normal qu'il
puisse y avoir condamnation là en
l'occurrence il n'ya pas condamné
j'imagine que les juges s'ils ont décidé
d'une mise en examen parce qu'ils
avaient reçu de très nombreuses plaintes
c'est qu'ils ont considéré qu'il fallait
que l' enquête se poursuivre et que
qu'il y avait déjà des éléments qui
nécessitait une poursuite de l'enquêté
pour l'instant elle n'est pas condamné
mais pour pouvoir répondre à la question
que vous avez posé il faut bien qu'une
enquête puisse se dérouler à charge et à
décharge mais c'est le principe de notre
justice aujourd'hui il ne faut pas que
les affaires politiques et le débat
politique se règle devant les tribunaux
et on est les premiers à le dire puisque
même on nous a renvoyés devant les
tribunaux donc il faut pas qu'ils se
passent devant les tribunaux mais il
faut aussi que la justice puisse faire
son travail et que les hommes et les
femmes politiques ne soient pas au
dessus des lois donc nous verrons bien
ce que l' enquête va donner et quel que
soit le résultat de l'enquète et quel
que soit le résultat à la fin pour agnès
buzyn ce qui est sûr c'est que de notre
côté nous nous pouvons dire que
politiquement il ya eu un problème que
politiquement cette crise a été mal géré
et quand on voit que emmanuel mac os
continuent à supprimer des vies pendant
la crise que l'année dernière il a
encore supprimé 1800 lee 1800 lit alors
qu'on nous sommes en pleine crise
sanitaire qu'il en avait supprimé 4,6 me
l'année précédente commente à 5000 lits
supprimés sur 20 ans il ya un problème
politique de fond auxquels ces gens ou
aussi participé et dont ils devront
rendre des comptes cette fois là
peut-être pas dans la justice mais
devant le peuple français justement
c'est ce type de décision parler de
l'augmentation des lits qui aurait pu
peut-être éviter certains drames comme
on l'a vu dans ce témoignage de gens il
faut bien dire parce que c'est pas le
premier que l'on entend tous qui sont
morts seuls sont leurs familles si les
pitot étaient mieux gérer est ce que
c'est votre opinion aussi jean philippe
dugoin témoins
oui enfin il n'y a pas que le sujet les
est aussi un élément parmi d'autres -
trentenaire ça fait 18 mois que j'ai pu
vivre les incohérences le l'état sur
beaucoup de sujets l'un des sujets
décideurs ne dépend pas de ce
gouvernement date pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est la paupérisation ou la limitation
des moyens hospitaliers auxquels on a
été confronté encore une fois
objectivement je suis pas convaincu que
la situation de l'hôpital aujourd'hui
elle résulte uniquement de la question
et de la situation de madame busin voit
là est
le véritable débat qui fait reposer
c'est à une situation politique à la
façon dont a été gérée ou non gérer une
crise politique mans revient une réponse
politique et cette réponse politique
doit avoir lieu dans les urnes elle doit
avoir lieu en avril prochain et en juin
prochain mais je pense que la
judiciarisation une étape politique et
faire quelque chose qui est extrêmement
dangereux et pour revenir à ce que vous
disiez alors dans le cas de la france
insoumise on n'est pas lié à l'exercice
du pouvoir là on n'est pas sur une
attaque de monsieur mélenchon par
rapport aux prises de position
politiques qui sont les siennes cesti si
on va sur le grill ici une
juridiciarisation du pouvoir par m'en
excuser moi pourrait être le cas et
c'est ça que je trouve ces glissements
que je trouve dangereux encore une fois
et dernière chose encore une fois s'il
doit y avoir une mise en cause d'un
ministre sur ce sujet je peux le
concevoir je trouve rendent extrêmement
tôt pour l'heure clair la crise de la
comida n'est pas terminé on demande aux
milices la santé qui a succédé à man à
buzeins de continuer à gérer cette crise
on demandera au successeur de monsieur
verrons dans quelques mois doit
continuer à gérer cette crise comment le
ministre de la santé qui sera en poste
pour succéder à monsieur ou madame busin
va être amené à gérer une crise sachant
que son ou ses prédécesseurs sont
poursuivis en justice c'est juste la
question que je pose et je pense que au
jeu et je pense que en allant trop vite
on met tout simplement la capacité de
réaction et d'action de l'état en danger
simplement pour dire il y avait un moyen
aussi peut-être pour que l'on en a voilà
c'est celui d'avoir vendu des comptes
politiques pendant la crise pourquoi
aujourd'hui il ya eu des centaines dans
des milliers de plaintes contre le
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
ne rendez vous il ya un désir de
réponses politiques
réponse politique c'est vrai devant le
peuple peut-être que si les décisions
avaient été
systématiquement ou de manière beaucoup
plus régulière au moins sur des
orientations prises devant l'assemblée
nationale qu'il y avait eu des votes de
l'assemblée nationale il y aurait eu un
débat politique avec une opposition avec
une majorité et peut-être les décisions
auraient été similaires mais peut-être
pas mais en tout cas les françaises et
les français auraient pu voir la
décision se prendre aurait pu voir de
justification
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
on a eu cent seize villes mort du co
vide 7 millions de personnes contaminées
en france et où personne ne comprend
comment les décisions ont été prises
aujourd'hui encore les décisions se
prennent en conseil de défense sous le
sceau du secret sans savoir qu'ils
participent qui propose sans que des
contre arguments depuis cet exposé et à
chaque fois que le gouvernement se rend
devant le parlement c'est pour présenter
ce qu'il a déjà décidé avant même que ce
soit votée donc il n'y a pas de débat on
ne peut pas gérer une crise de cette
ampleur sans qu'il y ait de
justification politique sans qu'il y ait
de départ et c'est pour ça que ça
interroge également sur la gestion
globale de notre système politique et
sur la nécessité de remettre les choses
à plat pour ça que nous avec jean luc
mélenchon propose qu'en 2022 ce soit le
cas avec une sixième république dernière
question jean philippe dugoin tellement
on se souvient qu'en 2018 un emmanuel
lacroix avait réitéré son sa promesse de
supprimer la cour de justice de la
république un françois hollande avait
fait d'ailleurs d'eux mêmes promesses
non tenues en tout cas pour l'instant
peau pour les deux pourquoi elles sont
si compliqués de la supprimer est-ce que
surtout il fallait le faire
chez réalisé que les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les reçoivent
aujourd'hui doit s'en mordre les doigts
plaisanterie m mise à part
il reviendrait dessus
bien vrai
il ya un vrai sujet aujourd'hui et je
rebondis sur ce que disait l'autre
intervenant il ya aujourd'hui un défaut
de responsabilité politique il n'y a pas
de responsables politiques qui va l'être
des lignes qui va reconnaître cette
plante et où avoir échoué et cette
absence de responsabilité politique la
façon très centralisé pour ne pas dire
que dont a été géré la crise ça amène
aussi un certain nombre de citoyens
parce qu'il pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
réponse politique de réponse
administratifs ils soient apportées à se
tourner vers la recherche d'une réponse
pénale ce qui pour le coup je pense a
les effets induits qui peuvent être
pires qu'autre chose pour notre capacité
future à répondre mais ça doit aussi
nous interroger sur le fait que
l'exercice du pouvoir hypercentralisé on
a aujourd'hui il n'est plus adapté à la
france du xxième siècle il est plus
adapté au mode de fonctionnement on a
aujourd'hui est que le hêtre politique
c'est aussi être responsables sept
responsables politiques mangerons les
plus on risque de glisser vers des
responsabilités pénales qui sont pour le
coup extrêmement
dangereuse pour l'action publique
le mot de la fin effectivement sur cette
suppression de
vous rappeler qu'en général la
proposition c'est que on supprime la
cour de justice de la république pour ne
pas avoir de justice à deux vitesses
c'est donc pas à supprimer la cour de
justice de la république pour faire en
sorte que le gouvernement soit aux deux
autres mais condé il voulait offert
d'aider des justiciables comme les
autres de ses ministres simplement on
supprime la cour de judo mais qu'on en
fait des justiciables comme les autres
et donc ils sont responsables devant la
justice ordinaire ce qui n'empêche pas
qu'il n'y aurait pas pu y avoir de mise
en examen puisque la justice de droit
commun peut tout à fait mettre en examen
quelqu'un pour non assistance à personne
en danger donc ça ne résout pas le
problème voire peut-être par rapport à
ce qui a été fait c'est dans sa banalise
le recours à la justice voilà je pense
que le plus important à la sortie de
cette crise c'est effectivement
d'affirmer qu'on a besoin à un retour de
la démocratie qu'on a besoin de se
défaire de cette sorte d' autoritarisme
de cette centralisation des pouvoirs
dans les mains du président de la
république qui ressemble plus à un
monarque républicain car un président de
la république et qu'il faut un repos à
la responsabilité politique nous propose
des solutions course à la sixième
république
le référendum révocatoire le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui ont été
portées aux aussi parler gilet jaune
donc voilà il est temps que les choses
changent il est temps d'amener des
propositions et il est temps aussi que
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
s'interroge sur ce qu'ils ont fait et
assument leurs responsabilités
politiquement merci en tout cas à tous
les deux d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france et d'avoir accepté ce
face-à-face merci messieurs